[Music]
tell these guys the boys are coming to
with the basic models they should be any
[ __ ] minute what's happened you bad
[ __ ] as usual the church never
stops always [ __ ] creepin while you're
sleeping you understand me
you weren't even prepared for this one
you dirty [ __ ] well here in the
green room at the punchline ready to go
[ __ ] deep for the second show if you
came for the first show you came last
night you're a [ __ ] savage you
understand me but as usual I'm not gonna
leave you out there hanging we had a
good week I hope you enjoyed the podcast
I hope your family's healthy you got to
work this Roach to the [ __ ] up I don't
give a [ __ ] about your fingertips if you
want to crack safes you gotta smoke a
roach to the nub
but as usual we're not [ __ ] around
tonight even in Sacramento we bring our
own [ __ ] with us that's how we roll we
don't take chances only [ __ ] amateurs
take chances well I have a friend I got
no friends we bring our own [ __ ] with us
tip-top Magoo fresh to the [ __ ] boy
you understand me
look at this beautiful twinkle twinkle
little star how I wonder how you are oh
yeah we're going deep and just when you
thought it was safe look who's here the
Christ killer ready to go quit waiting
crystal not so crystal
one shot we need ten tonight we're going
deep I don't think we'll make it home
tonight but the good thing is is a
Mexican join up the corner to look at
that was one off I got it down to the
[ __ ] you can take them don't think
about that we need to take no just keep
eating we're gonna face that bad we
don't give a [ __ ] if it's brand new
this is this this bag is not it listen
in my world weed is not a museum open up
that going get the waitress get those
little spanish wages you thought I was
gonna forget about your [ __ ] on
a Friday night
never you're the heart and soul you're
the [ __ ] tip-top Magoo of everything
you understand I love you [ __ ]
it's me with you you're with me and they
want to be with us anyway I just figured
I'd check up on you [ __ ]
Sacramento the punch line one show last
night one down we got the second one
coming tonight and it's all over then we
got the weekend and that's it
[ __ ] I just want tap them with
you and make sure I got to tell you I
love you and I hope you have a great
weekend I hope your family's the same
and I hope you out of the fires and I
hope [ __ ] Kim Jungman got his hands
on you cuz it's a bet where's react he's
throwing away the stars you gotta watch
me like a hawk cuz he won't eat the
[ __ ] stars he'll tell me he ate him
but then he'll give him away or
something like that she know us always
we send them ahead of time by the time
we get to the hotel the UPS man is
bringing to us that's how we roll
[ __ ] if you're gonna be a
smuggler wife smuggle have the
government do it for you
[Laughter]
and that's it and that's that I just
wanted to make sure you guys knew uncle
Joey loved you and had your back
that's it and that's that have a great
weekend and I'll see you Monday night
eight o'clock tip top Magoo ready to go
we ain't [ __ ] around no more
stay black have a good weekend and stand
in the way I sis they're all pissed off
Jerusalem the whole [ __ ] thing